this is starting to sort of get repetitive.
I think it's still really
important to do.
We have a cycle that has become very common
in modern American politics.
The president makes a completely unrealistic
promise.
He then fails to deliver on that promise.
Then he brags about the results even though
they fall short of his promise.
Then we find out he criticized a democratic,
uh, operative of politician or prior president
for the exact same result.
This time it's Barack Obama over the GDP and
Donald Trump's prediction of four or five
or even 6% GDP growth.
Let me set it up for you and we'll get right
into it.
GDP is the gross domestic product.
It's one of the main ways that we measure
the size of our economy.
There's a lot of debate over whether GDP is
the right way to evaluate an economy.
But putting that aside for now, this is the
total value of all the stuff we produce in
the services that we provide in a year.
That's our GDP.
During his campaign and after becoming president,
Donald Trump was talking about we're going
to have 3% GDP growth, 4% GDP growth, five
even 6% GDP growth.
Here's just one example of Donald Trump doing
this.
This one's during his presidency.
He's been predicting it since he was just
candidate Trump.
But to get going in a way, I really want where
we have GTP getting up to four or five and
even 6% because I think that's possible.
If you look back in your notes, you'll say,
when I said 4% uh, people said that would
be years.
Well, it's turned out that I'm right because
without the hurricanes, this last quarter,
we would have hit 4%
so of course none of this has happened.
And yesterday we learned that in the third
quarter of this year, the GDP was just 1.9%
now, just it's actually pretty normal.
That's a relatively normal level of GDP growth.
It's not particularly good or particularly
bad, but the thing is, Donald Trump is now
cheering it as if it is a signal of the best
economy ever.
Literally tweeting yesterday, quote the greatest
economy in American history, but back in 2012
when Barack Obama had the exact same 1.9%
GDP growth, what did Donald Trump tweet?
Because there's a tweet for everything.
Donald Trump tweeted, Q1 GDP has just been
revised down to 1.9% the economy is in deep
trouble, and of course it wasn't.
But if it was, then Trump's economy must likewise
be in deep trouble on the basis of those same
GDP numbers.
So this is one more of Donald Trump's insane
predictions and his distortions and his being
the pot that calls the kettle black.
But this is also economically disastrous.
And I'm going to tell you why.
Remember Donald Trump, when he told us about
his tax cut plan was told that's going to
blow up the deficit.
It doesn't balance.
It's going to explode the deficit.
And Donald Trump said, no, no, no.
This tax cut plan is going to cause such growth.
We're going to cause you know, 3% 4% 5% 6%
GDP growth that the growth will pay for the
tax cuts in a way that none of the analysts
are coming clean with you about.
The proposal for tax cuts was scored and it
was a train wreck, totally underwater, hugely
deficit exploding, but his acolytes repeated
this claim.
They said the estimates are wrong.
GDP will be up up, up five, 6% it'll pay for
the tax cuts in total.
Now, aside from whether that makes sense at
all, and I would argue it doesn't, it's what
he claimed and it is not happening and his
followers are falling for it.
We were told the GDP will go up so much that
the tax cuts will be paid for and everything
is going to be so good.
Everybody will win every just winning for
everybody and instead the opposite has happened
and we are now curating or maybe there's a
better way of saying it.
Trumpism is curating one of the lowest information,
electorates that actually thrives on Trump
lies and is energized by the distortions,
which they can then go and repeat all over
the internet and Twitter and the normal enclaves
applying no critical analysis whatsoever either
because they're choosing not to apply any
critical analysis or because they lack the
intellectual capacity and knowledge of critical
thinking and epistemology that might be required
to do that analysis of what Donald Trump is
telling them, but it is hugely damaging to
the economy.
It's hugely damaging to the fabric of the
country in terms of just basic intellectual
rigor and thinking and it has opened the door
for this to become the absolute new norm.
Normal in future presidencies.
In future campaigns where promises don't matter.
Any failed promise by the person on your quote
team is either because someone is misstating
what the promise was or because of the other
party that got in the way or because of where
the [inaudible] it doesn't even matter what
it is, will excuse it saying in some way,
shape or form.
The left does this to some degree it's not
as bad, but I don't want to do it and if you
see me doing it then I hope you will call
me out for applying a different standard to
the left than than the right.
One of my priorities and I think I'm doing
an okay job of it, is when the same criticism
could apply to both parties.
I apply it to both parties.
When there are differences between the parties,
I point out what they are and when the status
quo is either implicitly or explicitly reinforced
by both parties, uh, because it's more of
an establishment versus anti-establishment
thing.
I hope that I'm pointing that out to you as
well.
If I'm, if I'm falling short of that goal,
I do want you to let me know.